I have two cats at home
they were mostly wonderful except when
they're terrible I think most cat owners
know that their cats are smart and
affectionate they are cat Jasper but
when I'm outside with him he'll look at
me he'll look at the wall he'll look
back at me and if I bend over he jumps
on my back and he jumps on the wall and
so there's this complex community can't
talk to me it's very clear to me what he
wants and it's very clear to him how to
communicate what he was with me um David
Grimm on the online news editor at
science so for a long time scientists
did not study cats and dogs when it came
to study what we call social cognition
this is the idea of studying how cats
and dogs and other animals were allayed
to us as human beings there was this
idea that everything we've done over
domestication had sort of created this
kind of fuzzy signal whereas if you
studied the mind of a chimpanzee or crow
you're getting a pure or signal because
this is an animal that has not been bred
or selected to live with people in any
way now that all changed in 1998 when
two independent labs showed that dogs
could understand what we mean we pointed
an object so if you pointed an object or
even a toddler understands look at that
thing
and when we do that with chimpanzees
they don't understand that at all they
have no idea what we're doing but lo and
behold in 1998 a couple of labs showed
that when they did that with dogs dogs
looked at the object and this was really
a really shocker for the field so today
there are more than a dozen labs around
the world that study canine cognition
and yet there's been almost nothing with
cats
researchers have largely ignored cats
and while they've been focusing a lot of
energy on dogs one of the reasons that
scientists avoid studying cats is that
they're very difficult to work with you
bring a dog into a laboratory and for
the MOOC for the most part this dog
wants to please him so taking them to a
lab is not a big deal it's pretty easy
to work with dogs cats are another story
they you know a lot of cats are just
kept in the home all the time so taking
them to a new environment is very scary
for them there was a study in 2005 the
showing cats can do human pointing but
even the GNAT study a lot of the cats
dropped out in study which man they
basically wouldn't cooperate they either
just left the room a lot of them just
sort of walked away from the testing
site for the most part cats after a few
trials they're just they've had they're
done you know
all these problems made it very
difficult to do these studies which is
why even when this first study came out
in 2005 nobody really followed up on
including the lab that actually did the
work and it wasn't until about five or
six years ago that we've started to see
kind of this uptick again in people
starting to look at cats again in terms
of social cognition Oregon State
University they're one of the big cat
labs in the world and one of the things
that they're doing is really studying
this social connection that cats have
with people one of the tests to do is is
is called an attachment test and
basically what this involves is the
owner of the cat will go into a room so
the cats kind of all freaked out because
they were in this room and they don't
know what's going on and yes their
owners there but whatever and then the
owner leaves and then the cats were
really freaked out right and the cats
will tend to be a lot the growth circles
all of us it's like they're kind of
panicking and then the owner comes back
into the room sits down on the ground
and often the cat will come running back
to the owner and then something very
interesting happens all of a sudden they
will leave the owner and they will start
exploring the room sniff out the corners
maybe there's a toy on the floor they'll
play with the toy and the average person
will look at that and go well clearly
the cat doesn't care about their owner
their owners there and all the cat wants
to do is explore their room but it's
actually the opposite that's true the
cat has such a close bond with their own
or that they go okay now my owners here
so now I am free to do what I'd like to
do as a cat which is kind of go out and
explore they also do this test which an
Italian group pioneered basically what
it involves is you know again Mehcad
neo-noir in this this white lab room and
the research was bringing in this
objects it's a fan with these streamers
attached to it and then the researchers
will turn the fan on so of course the
fan this fans blowing to make a lot of
noise and cats will get obviously pretty
freaked out about that and then what the
owner does is the owner is instructed to
make nice with a fan what a nice fan
what a lovely fan you know if you want
to meet the fan you want to touch the
fan do you want to get to know the fan
and sometimes the owner watch you go up
and touch the fan and what's really
surprising and some cats we'll all of a
sudden they kind of calm down they'll
approach the fan when the owner
approaches the fan and I ain't even
solve one situation where a cat went
right up to the fan and just laid down
right in front of the fan which is kind
of remarkable this is an object that
just a couple of minutes ago that was
scaring the stuffing out of them and all
of a sudden the air feeling comfortable
now with it because they picked on up on
these emotional cues from their owner
like
oh this isn't something I should be
afraid of and so all these things like
following human gaze understanding our
emotional states show the cat's very
much like dogs are very tuned into us
which makes a lot of sense we're took
again we're talking about creatures that
not only have to live in our homes but
it really have to anticipate what do we
mean when we do things are we angry at
them are we happy with them do we want
them to look at something do we want
them to do something without them
understanding that it really would be
fairly impossible for us to have the
kind of relationship we have with these
animals otherwise even though it looks
like things are starting to come
together for cat cognition we've gotten
a handful of labs around the world
studying cats we've got papers coming
out one of the big open questions is
whether this is at the beginning of a
movement a big movement for cats or
whether it's going to continue to be a
very niche part of science just because
there's only a few people out there that
are actually willing to work with cats
some of the things are interested in
looking at is can cats categorize things
so we know that dogs can actually after
a little bit of trial and error figure
out like if they're being shown a
picture of a landscape or picture of
another dog so you may be shown a few
pictures of lakes and mountains and you
show them pictures of other dogs and it
turns out dogs can do that and so now
one research Russian wants to try that
with cats to see if cats can also
categorize things no pun intended I
guess you know cats have this reputation
of being aloof and anti-social and even
dumb when it comes to things like oh you
know cats can't do tricks and all this
other stuff but what this research is
showing is that there whatever tricks
dogs were able to pick up over the
course of evolution cats also pick up a
lot of those tricks it's just that we
haven't spent enough time looking for
them we haven't found a great way to
study cats and once we do likely we're
going to see that there's a lot of
complexity going on the cat brain and
there's a lot of complexity in the
relationship between cats and people we
just need to do the studies to find that
out
[Music]
[Music]